ma première question est très générique quel
était votre sentiment général à propos de Victor
Wen banyama a-t-il répondu à vos
attentes,
il a répondu à ce que j'attendais,
euh, je veux dire que j'avais de grandes attentes
pour lui et en fait, vous savez,
pour être honnête, il  a probablement dépassé les
attentes que j'avais
euh il y a peut-être environ un mois je ne
pensais pas qu'il jouait
je pensais qu'il jouait beaucoup mais je
pensais qu'il jouerait probablement peut-être 20
minutes par match je ne pensais pas qu'il
aurait aimé  vraiment de très bonnes
statistiques juste parce que vous savez que vous
ne voyez pas vraiment en Europe des gars mis en place
comme des chiffres statistiques fous, puis
après les matchs à 234 points,
puis je pense qu'il en avait 23 lors du premier match
de la saison, j'étais comme d'accord  ce
mec va mettre des chiffres énormes et
euh vous savez qu'il a eu des problèmes de faute dans le
premier match j'étais là et puis le
deuxième match il en avait 19. mais je dirai il y a un
mois si vous m'auriez posé la
question il est dépassé  ces
attentes  ns mais j'avais de grandes
attentes pour lui
euh en entrant dans ces deux jeux que j'ai
vus la semaine dernière d'accord, nous savons tous euh
les compétences exceptionnelles de Victor Long Tall
pour sa reproduction de taille Mobilité ma
question ma deuxième question est
quelle partie de son jeu  n'est pas assez
souligné Peut-être sous-évalué
le match euh je ne peux pas mais le match de
mardi soir
le portail ouais j'ai commencé avec les noms
des équipes de France parce que c'est comme
s'ils avaient quatre ou cinq noms parfois
mais dans ce match en deuxième mi-temps je
signifie qu'il a fait des lectures vraiment impressionnantes à
partir des passes de contact élevées euh
c'est presque comme
s'il avait tellement de
parties de son jeu qu'il n'a pas vraiment
eu l'occasion de montrer l'année dernière
également et maintenant il montre aux gens
ce qu'il peut faire  et c'est comme si vous saviez que
les attentes étaient élevées, je veux dire qu'il a
été projeté pour être le choix numéro un
au cours des deux dernières années, mais maintenant il
montre
un niveau différent de passes et de
compétences que je veux dire même comme le  les plus
grands fans de win-bayama doivent être satisfaits de
ce qu'ils étaient ce qu'ils disent donc
je dirais que c'est le passé qui m'a définitivement pris
par surprise et qu'avez-vous
pensé de son rôle dans les
métropolitains vous sentez-vous comme
son  décision de partir aussi pour aller
jouer il y en avait une bonne ouais je
pense vraiment que c'était le bon
choix dans lequel il est
vous savez vraiment une situation parfaite c'est
plus proche de chez lui il a comme vous l'avez dit la
liberté de
vous savez juste faire des choses différentes  Je veux dire
qu'Asbell est une équipe dont vous savez qu'elle est
très compétitive et qu'évidemment, en
planifiant l'Euro League, il n'y a vraiment
pas beaucoup de temps pour se développer lorsque vous
planifiez une année parce que vous savez que
tout est une question de gagnant-gagnant-gagnant  et je pense que dans
cette situation avec les métropolitains, je
veux dire bien sûr, vous savez qu'il veut
gagner et l'équipe veut gagner mais
ils lui donnent
vous savez la liberté de faire des
erreurs et vous pouvez au moins à mon
avis je peux  voir qu'il est totalement
différent  joueur en ce qui concerne la confiance
comme il a toujours été confiant, mais
ce gars que nous voyons en ce moment est
extrêmement confiant et donc
cela vaut à lui seul le transfert d'
Asheville à Metropolitan, nous
parlons évidemment beaucoup avec NBA Scouts
um American NBA Scouts  quel est le
sentiment général là-bas euh est Victor un
numéro un clair euh est-ce une course avec
scoot y a-t-il d'autres perspectives dans
le mélange
ouais je veux dire je pense que c'est c'est euh c'est
Victor d'abord et ensuite je pense toujours que c'est
une marge assez large  entre Victor et
scoop, mais je pense que ces deux-là sont les
deux premiers dans une sorte de classe à
part entière, puis après cela, c'est un peu
grand ouvert pour le numéro trois, mais tous ceux avec
qui j'ai parlé l'ont numéro
un juste parce que je veux dire  nous n'avons jamais rien vu de
tel auparavant, nous n'avons jamais
vu quelqu'un de cette taille bouger comme
il le fait et comme ses seuls impacts défensifs le
feraient savoir, euh, une
personne qui serait considérée pour le
premier choix
mais  maintenant, une fois que vous ajoutez ce qu'il a
du côté offensif et le développement
qu'il a fait, je pense que ça
va être vraiment très difficile pour l'école
de les réussir et je dis même que je pense que
la seule façon dont l'école pourrait les réussir est
si
vous savez qu'il y a des
problèmes de blessures ou quelque chose qui s'inquiète des
blessures mais vous savez que c'est quelque chose
qui va souvent être discuté quand
vous avez quelqu'un de cette taille ouais et nous
avons l'exemple de la blessure récente de chat Holmgren
euh je veux dire évidemment ils
ont le même morphotype  lui Invicta est-ce que les
gens sont un peu inquiets à
propos du mofotype soi-disant sujet aux blessures
ouais je ne pense pas, je veux dire, je
pense que peut-être que les fans sont probablement plus vocaux
à ce sujet, mais je veux dire que la blessure de Chet était,
je veux dire, les échecs n'ont jamais vraiment eu d'
antécédents de blessures  avant cela et c'était juste
la blessure de lui se blessant au pied en
jouant dans le jeu, ce n'était pas une
blessure au genou ou quelque chose comme ça et je
pense que vous le savez malheureusement
parce que Chet  a un
cadre et une longueur de style de corps similaires à ceux de Victor
qu'une fois que le contrôle a été blessé, les gens
vont commencer à faire des suppositions
que c'est lié à leur taille et à
leur taille que cette blessure Chet
aurait pu m'arriver et vous
euh deux contre un pour finir  cette interview
Rafael senior tweete sur euh la mauvaise
qualité des séquences vidéo bad click Elite
euh je dois dire que je suis d'accord je pense que beaucoup de
gens en France sont d'accord avec vous mais est-
ce un sentiment partagé au sein de la
communauté scoute américaine après Victor sommes-nous les
Français embarrassants  nous-mêmes
étant très loin derrière en ce qui concerne le
marketing de la communication, en particulier en
ligne,
je veux dire, je pense juste que la façon dont l'
arène est configurée que la vue est un
peu comme si vous regardiez par-dessus
lui plutôt que comme un autre  Regardez
et puis
euh les images sortent toujours un peu
sombres quand vous les coupez ensemble
euh
mais vous savez je veux dire que c'est juste que le basket-ball
en Amérique est très différent en France
vous k  maintenant comme moi, je dirais que si
nous avions une victoire ici aux États-Unis, je
veux dire qu'il y aurait ce serait impossible
d'obtenir un billet
euh tu sais je veux dire Paris est comme une ville
où il y a tellement de choses à faire alors peut
-être que c'est un  une partie de cela peut-être que le basket-ball
n'est pas seulement le numéro un
euh alors vous savez le sport numéro un en
France
euh alors oui c'est un peu différent
des États-Unis je veux dire comme même ici
aux États-Unis s'il y a un très bon
joueur de lycée  Je veux dire qu'il
va y avoir plusieurs caméramans multiples
qui le suivront partout,
mais je pense que peu importe de
quel pays il s'agit, je veux dire, je pense que les
États-Unis et je ne dis pas cela
parce que je suis américain mais  Je pense que les
États-Unis viennent de maîtriser le
marketing et l'image de marque et de créer une
exposition
pour le jeu ERS et c'est en
fait trop négatif parce que nous
avons des enfants
ici qui ont comme 14 ou 15 ans
et ils ont tellement d'exposition
qu'ils pensent  qu'ils l'ont fait ils
pensent que  t ils ont déjà,
ils pensent qu'ils ont déjà
réussi, donc il y a un côté négatif
à avoir autant d'exposition,
euh, mais oui, je suis juste un peu choqué
que euh
qu'une partie de la qualité de certains
des jeux soit  ce n'est pas euh et comme la
plus grande qualité d'autant plus que
vous avez comme un talent générationnel à
Victor eh bien nous allons essayer d'améliorer les choses
je pense euh en envoyant un message à tous les
premiers ministres je pense ouais je pense
qu'il pourrait y avoir
je ne m'y attendais pas  mon commentaire pour atteindre le
premier ministre mais euh non il semble qu'il
y ait beaucoup de gens qui semblent être d'
accord que oui la qualité n'est pas ou ça
pourrait être mieux je devrais dire oui
oui oui tu as raison beaucoup beaucoup de  les gens
et les amis sont je me plains
de cette séquence vidéo dans la façon dont les
jeux sont filmés donc depuis de nombreuses années donc
évidemment tu n'es pas seul dans
ce combat
merci merci quand même Raphael d'
avoir été euh notre premier invité  ça a
été un plaisir pas de problème quand tu
veux  faites-moi savoir et nous pouvons euh nous
pouvons certainement y arriver
J'apprécie l'invitation et tous ceux
qui écoutent vont lire le travail de Rafael
et soyez un grand conseil qu'il vous a donné
comme un avant-goût ici mais il y a beaucoup plus
sur le site  évidemment, les informations Pro d'Intel
et la couverture étendue du repêchage de la
NBA, il ne s'agit pas uniquement de Victor, continuez votre
bon travail, Rafael et vous êtes toujours
le bienvenu dans notre émission